Okay, here's my question. Forget the
beloved part. You say they're not
beloved, but they're sons. So, here's
very simple. Show us a verse in the
Quran that says believers who at one
time were Jews and Christians, but now
it's you Muslims. You are the sons and
daughters of Allah. That's all I'm
asking. That's it. Simple. See, I don't
need to take 30 seconds.
>> So, my answer to that question is this.
when if I mean God does not deny people
when they would want to relate to him as
their father that's just one attribute
they can do it there's no problems if
God were to deny it the denial would
have been the negation would have been
in 5:18 God would have said don't call
me as your father because I'm not God
never said that so that tells you if you
want to relate to God as your father you
can there's no problem but the problem
becomes apparent when you are literally
understanding God has a biological
relationship with us which there which
there isn't
That's when it becomes problematic.
>> Okay. Now, let me give push back to
that. Let me repeat what I said earlier.
No Jew or Christian at the time of
Muhammad thought they were the
biological children of Allah. So, they'd
had sex with them. They meant it
spiritually.
You keep going to the part that God has
no problem. And I'm telling you, the
Quran has a problem because when it says
the beneficent had taken unto himself a
son, it doesn't mean sexually. Because
it also says that those who say he has
taken a wife, but here taken can also
mean adopt. We'll get there into the
Arabic. But now even if I grant to you
that here Allah is denying that he has a
son biologically, why then does he say
there is none in the heavens and earth
but cometh unto the benefits as a slave?
Why didn't your God say you can come to
me as a son as long as it's not
biological? Why did he say all you are
are slaves? No one in the heavens and
earth is anything but a slave. So your
God just refuted you. So I'm going to
ask the question. Show us in the Quran
where believers can be children of God.
And I'm not talking biological. The Jews
and Christians believe that. I just gave
you a verse that says all you are are
slaves. That's it.
>> So the Quran treats Jewish and Christian
peoples as fellow believers like
co-believers. So they the Quran did
consider the Jewish and the Christian
diaspora as a mun
belonging to the same group of believing
people. So if they related to God as
their father, the Quran did not object.
So that tells you a lot. And the
objection that the Quran has against is
when the Christians asserted that Jesus
is the begotten child of Almighty God.
>> So that's when the Quran double downs
and says no, God does not have a son.
Don't change it to Jesus because
>> I'm not changing. Don't accuse me of
anything.
>> I'm just straightforward answering.
>> I'm sorry. I'm just straight forward.
>> Secretity. I'm going to give you another
chance.
>> I just want to jump in real quick
because I want to make sure I'm on the
same.
>> So So I just want to make sure I'm on
the same page. Same with the audience.
Sam,
>> are you wondering and correct me if I'm
wrong.
>> Yes. for Daniel to show us in the Quran
where believers can be children of God
spiritually, not just physically, where
one might say that, you know, we're all
creatures of God.
>> And Daniel, you're basically saying,
well, the Quran doesn't directly state
>> that we are that that believers are
children of God. But because it doesn't
say that we're not, then
>> no, he says actually Allah has no
problem with it. Now, Donnie, I'm gonna
talk to you for now. Number one, it says
there's no one in heaven and earth but
comes to him as a slave. That's number
one. I want you to see this, Donnie. And
then in 5:18, it says to the Jews, not
only are you not his beloved, the
context is you are not his beloved
children, his sons whom he loves. He
wants to now just focus in on the love
part because he can't deal with what his
own Quran is saying. So I'm asking him
if he's right that all Allah is saying
is you're not his beloved ones even
though you're his children then show us
where he says you're still my children
and Muslims are my children too.
I mean how hard is this man? We've been
here for 40 minutes.
>> What sort of a weird what sort of a
weird idea are you trying to inquire
here? The Quran does not negate it and
treats treats those Jewish and the
Christian communities as co-believers.
All right. And when while they are
referring to God as their father, the
Quran has no problems. It does not tell
them, "Stop calling me your father." The
Quran never said that to them, right?
>> Are you saying, Daniel, that the Quran
treats Christians and Jews who reject
the religion of Islam as co-believers?
>> We'll get to that. Don't let I don't
want to change the subject.
>> Okay. Okay. Sam, go ahead. You are not
required. You're not required to become
a Muslim uh in order to do
>> secure salvation. And you can secure
salvation being a Christian and being a
Jew and even being non-Abrahamic.
>> No, that's not true. That's why I said
he's going to change that because he's
going to run to 100% true. Help me,
Donnie. Help me.
>> Something
that I say because it breaks down his
against the Islamics
against Islam. Okay, let's throw it back
to Sam and then we'll throw back to you,
Daniel. Go.
>> Donnie, I want to feel to you. He said,
"Nor does the Quran say that you cannot
address God that way as a child." Right,
Donnie, can you read this for me one
more time?
>> There is there is none in the heavens
and the earth, but cometh unto thee
beneficent as a slave.
>> Now, Donnie, because I'm childish like
you said. Okay. If none in the heavens
and the earth will come to accept as a
slave, does that include Jews and
Christians on earth?
>> It also includes Jesus. Was Jesus
>> I'm not talking to you. I'm talking to
him. None. It's not just saying Jesus.
None. So if the Jews and Christians on
our earth and none will come except as a
slave, does that mean Jews and
Christians are only slaves?
>> Well, if it says none, then it' be all.
>> So how many times must I quote this
verse to show that his Quran says no one
is a son of God, no Jew, no Christian.
So we can avoid spending another hour
for him to admit what his Quran says.
How long will it take him for him to
admit?
>> Okay, here is the answer. Here is the
answer that you actually deserve. So in
in telling in God telling in we telling
God that you are our father, what does
it mean? What is the meaning behind it?
What have you achieved after relating to
God as your father? What have you
achieved?
>> Okay.
>> At the end of the day, he created you.
All of us, all of humanity beyond Jew,
Judeo-Christian
uh diaspora in the world, the entirety
of humanity are the creatures of
almighty God. And we serve his kingdom.
We serve his interests. We are serving
his interest. You you want to buy that
or you want to reject it. But that's
what is happening at the end of the day.
So the the factual relationship that we
have with God in this theology between
human being and almighty God is that of
a group of creatures who serve the
interests of God and therefore are
slaves.
>> Okay, here's why.
>> You achieve nothing by calling God your
father. You achieve nothing to be his
son.
>> All right. Well, let I'll let Jesus
>> the love that you express and God is
fine with that expression.
>> I will let Jesus rebuke you and show
that you don't know the true God. I'll
let Jesus rebuke you guys. He says you
achieved nothing, right?
>> Jesus himself was a servant of God
serving God.
>> Stop talking over me, man. And I'm going
to get to you. Show you from your Quran
that Jesus is more than a servant,
better than your prophet. Be patient.
John 8:30-36 Jesus says, "You don't know
what you're talking about." As he was
speaking these things, many believed in
him. So Jesus was saying to those Jews
who had believed him, "If you abide in
my word, then you are truly my
disciples. You will know the truth. The
truth will make you free." They answered
him, "We are Abraham's seed and have
never yet been enslaved to anyone. How
is it that you say you'll become free?"
Now, Donnie, I want you to listen. Jesus
answered,
>> "You want to manifest again or you want
me to finish?"
>> Sam, go ahead.
>> Jesus answered them, "Truly, truly I say
to you, everyone who commits sin is a
slave of sin, and the slave does not
remain in the house forever. The son
does remain forever. So, if the son
makes you free, you'll be free." Indeed,
Jesus just said, "You better become a
son of God, or if you're a slave, you
will not dwell in your father's house."
So, what do you mean, what difference
does it make? It proves that your God,
Allah, is not the God of the Bible. He's
a fake God. What are you not getting?
>> Okay. What you're not getting is this.
Basically, the Jewish premise when
stating that they are Abraham's seed and
we're not slaves to anybody is just
false. They spent centuries being
enslaved in Egypt. centuries focusing on
centuries. That's just a lie. It just it
just reflects their
>> devolved knowledge
concerning God and scriptures. They did
not have any knowledge of their they had
no idea what they were talking to Jesus
whatsoever.
>> Deal with Jesus.
>> Now look, now look what Jesus says. Now
Jesus says
Jesus Jesus says I'm not talking about
slave and the master kind of thing which
they had in Judea at the point in time.
Jesus says
>> the slavery is that you you submit
yourself
>> to something other than God such as
money man. You're you're hankering over
money and you're being slaved you're
being slaved to materialism.
So Jesus says, "Free yourself from there
and come back to God." That's what he
said.
>> It sounds like it sounds like according
to this verse, and if I'm understanding
Sam's argument correctly, to be a child
of God spiritually, then you have to be
a son of God. So you're no longer a
slave to sin.
>> Exactly. That's
>> was saying that we're all slaves. Jews,
Christians, Muslims.
>> Yeah. Now, Donnie,
>> not not saves us, not slaves of sin, but
slaves of God. He didn't say difference.
There's a difference. God says look in
this passage Jesus says and in fact God
teaches him this. Jesus says don't be
like a gentile seeketh after the
material world but seek a the kingdom of
God and his glory and his glory.
>> Now now what what what Jesus is saying
is you have to seek out the glory of the
kingdom of the lord.
>> All right? Stop going service that you
would provide. That's it. A little more
free flowing and organic. Let's let's
keep it at that point.
>> Stop going on tangents and give us a
sermon. Jesus said you must be a son.
You keep tap dancing. He didn't say
slave. The son does remain forever.
That's why the son came to set you free
to make you what? John 1:123. But as
many received him, to them he gave the
right to become children of God, not
slaves. Even those who believe in his
name, who were born not of blood, nor
the will of the flesh, nor the will of
man, but of God. That's why Jesus says,
"Blessed are the peacemakers." Matthew
5:9. For they shall be what? Oh, slaves
of God. No, sons of God. And Matthew
18:10, "See that you not despise one of
these little ones. For I say to you that
the angels in heaven continue see the
face of my father's heaven." So, I'm
going to give you a final chance. We're
going to move on because you wasted our
time. Show us in the Quran where it says
Jews, Christians, and you can be sons of
God. Black and white. Don't infer. Don't
give me your commentary. I don't want
Tapsi.
>> And before you answer, Daniel, I I do
want to I do want to reiterate listening
to this part, just being an objective
moderator.
Sam's scriptural references are very
direct and clear that we are children of
God through faith in Christ Jesus. I
mean, Jesus is just flat out saying
that. And so Sam, correct me if I'm
wrong, you're basically asking for that
same thing from Daniel, but from the
Quran. That's
>> Quran, not inference, not commentary. I
gave Look, Donnie, did I give
commentary? I read verses black and
white,
>> right? And and very clearly stating uh
what what you're arguing. So, uh Daniel,
I think Sam is basically just asking for
the same favor in return. where in the
Quran
>> look even
Peter speaking to the crowd said uh God
Jesus was God's servant. So if if he
wasn't the servant of God, Peter would
not have said it. So the the framework
of language that Sam is failing to
understand because of his childlike
brain cannot be explained in this
session. He has to go back and
contemplate on the scriptures and the
language found in the scriptures. Peter
himself said speaking to the crowd said
Jesus was a servant of God.
>> Okay. So you now ran to Acts 3 which is
now going to destroy your case. Let me
get there. But you said okay. All right.
Uh because remember Donnie he appealed
to Peter in Acts 3. I know where he's
referring to. Acts 3:13 and 26. He
thinks I don't know these verses. But
I'm going to show him the same Peter.
You better not object and say these are
corrupt. Matthew 16:15-1 17. He said to
them, "But who do you say that I am?"
And Simon Peter answered and said, "You
are the Christ, the son of the living
God." And by the way, the Greek word
paid, which is a Greek, can also mean
child. But I'll I'll even concede that
for you. How convenient you call Peter,
saying one thing, but ignore what Peter
says. All because these are corrupt.
Okay? You are the Christ, the son of the
living God. And Jesus answered and said
to him, "Blessed are you, Simon
Barjonah, because flesh and blood did
not reveal this to you, but my [snorts]
father, agreeing with Peter, he is my
father, just like Jonah's your father
who's in heaven." Second Peter 1:16:18,
Peter writing, "For we did not make
known to you the power and coming of our
Lord Jesus Christ, following cleverly
devised myths, but being eyewitnesses of
his majesty. For when he received honor
and glory from God the Father, such an
utterance as this was made to him by the
majestic glory, this is my beloved son
with whom I am well pleased. And we
ourselves heard this utterance made from
heaven when we were with him on the holy
mountain. Acts 1, when the apostles
asked him, is he going to restore the
kingdom? But he said to them, Acts 1:7,
"It is not for you to know times or
seasons which the Father has set by his
own authority." Why did you go to Acts
3:13:26?
And I'm going to go to that chapter.
It's going to really make it bad for you
because you just took snippets here.
Ignore what came before and elsewhere
because Peter said Jesus is not merely a
servant. He is the son of God. And you
still didn't answer the question. We
asked you show us in the Quran where it
says that Allah is your spiritual
father. You are spiritual children.
Please answer it.
>> Yes. Let's do this. Answer that question
real directly in 10 seconds or less.
Daniel, then feel free to respond to
these points that that Sam made because
I'm sitting here just kind of waiting to
write some notes.
>> Yeah, Donnie. Donnie, words by
themselves mean nothing. actions is what
brings out the reality the ground
realities. Okay, by action what I mean
is Jesus sitting down and washing the
feet of the disciples which they felt
awful to receive that service from him
goes on to demonstrate that Jesus was
acting as a servant of God. Washing feet
of people do you think anyone else other
than the servants would do?
>> Okay, good.
>> So actions speak louder than words. You
might use a very rosy framework of
language, the son of God, but your
actions is what goes on to define you.
All right? So, in that way, Jesus
defines himself as a servant of God.
Period.
>> Notice he didn't answer the question
again from the Quran, Donnie.
>> Yeah. Let's I I do want you to respond
to what he said there. Sam, let me
respond. I just I I do want to reiterate
this important point because from the
scriptures that Sam was showing, right,
from the Bible, right? For ye are all
children of God by faith in Christ
Jesus. But as many as received received
him, to them gave he power to become the
sons of God. Right? Spiritual salvation.
>> From John 13, brother, because he went
John 13 where Christ was washing their
feet. Again, being a typical Muslim, he
misqu. But I'll get there. So just can
you answer the questions? I go John 13,
which you misqued. Do you have a verse
that says Allah is your father
spiritually and you are sons? Yes or no?
I don't have to repeat myself.
>> Okay, that means no. All right, now
let's go to the context. Okay,
>> so are you saying no then Daniel? Just
just for my sake the audience for the
I just want to finish my thoughts. So is
is your answer no and then we can move
on because I feel like a lot of times
we're
>> Donnie I made I made great emphasis on
how there is it's not a problem to
relate to God as your father. All right,
there's there's no problem in it
>> spiritually. The only problem The only
problem comes when you insinuate a
literal biological relationship with
God. That's when God rebukes it and
condemns.
>> Would you agree with Sam? Well, Daniel,
would you agree with Sam that the Bible
is explicit, direct, clear that anybody
who believes, anybody who has faith as
as the the scriptures that Sam laid out
are children of God could call the
father spiritual father. But the Quran
doesn't really have a clear direct verse
like Bible does.
What what I mean to say is words need
backing and the actions of uh believers
in the Bible and in the Quran are no
different. The actions remain same but
you want to paint it with the word son.
Uh we don't we are not fond of painting
that worship to God as son or children.
>> Would you agree that the Bible's clear
asking I'm just asking a very simple
question so so the audience can have the
best possible answer and same with Sam.
The Bible's more clear in that respect
on that point than the Quran then is
what you'd say.
>> I don't necessarily say the Bible is
clear. The Bible just uses that
framework of language. That's what I can
say.
>> Okay. Let's throw it back to Sam. Go
ahead.
>> Okay. Now, notice he said John 13
because Jesus was a servant washed his
feet as if a child cannot be a servant
and serve. But now let's look. Let's
see. Well, let's read John. He just went
to John. The worst place you can go to,
brother. Jesus knowing that the father
had given all things into his hands. Oh,
that's in the same John 13 where Jesus
washed their feet and they had come
forth from God and he was going back to
God. Got up from supper and laid aside
his garments and taking a towel he tied
around himself. The same chapter where
you quote it saying his actions show
he's a servant is the same chapter that
shows you he's a son who serves who
humbles himself to be a servant as a son
because God is his father. And then
later after completely fine cut me off
buddy. I didn't cut you off. Let me
finish the point.
Don't manifest. Let me finish the point.
>> Redundant at this point in time.
>> John 13:12-14.
>> So when he had washed their feet and
taken his garments and reclined at the
table again, he said to them, "Do you
know what I've done to you? You call me
teacher and lord
rub. And you are right. You are right.
For so I am. If I then the Lord and the
teacher wash your feet, you also ought
to wash one another's feet." So now the
context for the audience is saying if I
am the Lord, one of the names of Allah
in Islam and the teacher, then you have
no excuse not to do what I'm doing. Why?
Because I am the Lord and the teacher
and you're my servants. In fact, he says
they are his servants. We're going to
get there, but it's in the same context
where it says God is his father. And now
since you went to John 16, remember the
pariclete? Let's go to that pariclete
passage because I want you to see that
in that same context. Who is God?
Is Jesus just a slave? Let's see. John
16:12-15.
I still have many more things to say to
you, but you cannot bear them now. But
when he, the Spirit of truth, comes, he
will guide you into all the truth. He
will not speak from himself, but
whatever he hears, he will speak, and
he'll disclose to you what is to come.
This is what started this, by the way,
Donnie. That's why I'm going back to
this. He will glorify me for he'll take
of mine and will disclose it to you. All
things that the father has are mine. And
this is the other point I want to make.
We'll get there. Therefore, I said that
he takes of mine and will disclose it to
you. Now, same chapter, Donnie. These
things, John 16:25-31,
I have spoken to you in figures of
speech. An hour is coming when I will no
longer speak to you in figures of
speech, but I will tell you openly of
the Father.
On that day, you will ask in my name,
and I do not say that to you that I will
request of the Father on your behalf.
For the Father himself loves you. Why?
Because you have loved me. And I believe
that I came forth from the Father. Like
the Spirit will come forth from the
Father. I came forth from the father and
I've come into the world. I'm leaving
the world and again going to the father.
Now Donnie watch he's not speaking
figuratively because look he says I
won't be speaking to you figuratively
but plainly and look his disciples said
behold now you are speaking openly and
are not using a figure of speech. Now we
know that you know all things, oh
omniscience. H and have no need to
anyone question you. By this we believe
that you came from God. Now he doesn't
rebuke them. Jesus answered them. Do you
now believe? And wait, I forgot to add
these. Sorry. I just want to do this. I
just want to add this. Okay. See, I come
with receipts from Quran in the Bible.
He's giving me commentary. But let's go
right here. Here. Behold, an hour is
coming and has already come for you to
be scattered each own home and to leave
me alone. Yet I'm not alone because the
father is with me. These things I have
spoken to you said in me you may have
peace in the world you have tribulation
but take courage I have overcome the
world. So the same passages he's quoting
it says God is the father and God is the
father of Jesus. Jesus is a son who came
from the father into the world and will
go to the to heaven to be with the
father and he knows all things and he's
not speaking figuratively. Why are you
butchering my Bible and misquing